Hi everyone.
I'm JZ.
Not the cool rapper,
(Laughter)
but the professor trying to cool
the planet through behavior change.
(Laughter)
The other day I gave
my students an assignment.
I asked them to come up
with individual actions they can take
that serve two functions:
reduce greenhouse gas emissions
and make themselves feel happier.
They did a great job coming up
with actions to reduce emissions,
but they had a much harder time
with the happiness part.
One student told me that he wanted
to cut back on cheese.
But right after he said that,
he got really sad.
(Laughter)
Unfortunately, my students are not alone.
When most people think
about climate action,
they immediately default to things
they have to give up for the planet.
This mindset is so ingrained in us,
partly because the current
narrative on climate action
is about personal sacrifice.
Drive less, eat less meat, shop less.
Less, less, less.
Now I'm a behavioral scientist,
so trust me when I say this,
this framing doesn't make us feel great.
If anything, it makes us feel
shameful and guilty.
And those negative emotions are not
conducive to long term behavior change
because they make us retreat
and disengage.
If the future of a planet
depends on a few people
willing to make personal sacrifices,
we're not going to make it.
(Laughter)
So what should we do instead?
The aha moment came to me
at the end of a faculty meeting
when my colleague, Elizabeth Dunn,
approached me and asked,
"Can we make climate action
feel happy instead of miserable?"
I said, "Of course."
But then it struck me
that I don't think anyone ever connected
happiness to climate action.
So Liz and I set down to do exactly that.
Liz is a happiness scientist.
She knows what makes people happy.
I'm a behavioral scientist.
I know what makes people
change their behavior.
I'm also a human carbon calculator.
I like figuring out exactly how much
emissions certain activities have.
So first I came up with a list of actions
that can substantially reduce
greenhouse gas emissions.
And then Liz identified the actions
with the largest happiness benefits.
And this is how we came up
with what we call
the happy climate approach.
It's actions in the sweet spot
that not only reduce emissions
but also make you feel happier
at the same time.
Now, I know that some of you may think
that individual actions may seem trivial
without large-scale system change.
I get that.
But let me tell you how I think
about this as a behavior change expert.
Our individual actions do matter
because they embody our values
and our care for the planet
to other people.
They can spread like a ripple effect
to instigate collective action.
They send a market signal to businesses
and they can trigger broader structural
institutional change.
So yes, we do need system change,
but we also need individual
behavior change.
Don't let anyone tell you otherwise.
Alright.
Now I want to take you on a whirlwind tour
through some of my favorite
happy climate actions.
Are you ready?
(Audience: Yes!)
Great.
Let's start with my pet bunny.
Since this is a year of the rabbit.
(Laughter)
A few years ago,
my partner and I adopted Greenwich.
(Laughter)
She's adorable.
She's also a vegan.
We have so many plants,
vegetables and fruits in our house,
thanks to Greenwich.
And because of that,
I'm eating a lot more
vegetables myself than I used to.
And I’m not kidding,
I'm feeling a lot happier.
Eating more plants can reduce agricultural
emissions by up to 80 percent.
I guess that part
you may have known before.
But do you also know that a plant-based
diet can make you feel happier?
Decades of medical studies suggest
that a plant-based diet can increase
both physical and mental health.
In a recent experiment,
researchers recruited people
from North Dakota
who barely ate any vegetables.
And they fed these people
a plant-based diet for two months.
These people, on this diet,
felt a lot happier
at the end of two months,
than they did before
they started the experiment.
So researchers think
that this is because plants --
so fruits, vegetables --
are high in vitamins and phytochemicals
that provide both antioxidant
and anti-inflammatory benefits
to the brain and the body.
So the happy climate action here
is eat more plants.
(Laughter)
But this does not mean never eat meat,
because I can tell you that deprivation
is a disaster for happiness.
Instead, we should aim
for the right balance
of meat and plants in our diet
that will make us maximally happy.
Now, as you're thinking
about this diet and this balance,
understand that not all
meat is created equal.
One kilogram of beef
emits about 100 kilograms
of greenhouse gases.
That's roughly the same
as driving 250 miles.
But other types of meat,
like fish, pork and poultry
have a lot lower emissions.
But if you do want to eat beef,
here's the happy climate hack:
make it a treat.
One study shows that temporarily
giving up something we enjoy
can actually renew our capacity to savor
that thing when we have it again.
And that can increase our happiness.
And beyond food, we can turn
other things into a treat as well,
like shopping.
Now you know that fast fashion
has a huge climate impact.
So instead of shopping often,
make shopping a treat.
And here's the happy climate hack.
Jackets, jeans, shoes have a lot
of greenhouse gas emissions.
So treating ourselves to high-quality
versions of these products
that won't fall apart after a few wears
is actually good for the planet.
Underwear, on the other hand,
have pretty low emissions.
So, you know, please buy those
whenever you need them.
(Laughter)
You're welcome.
Now let's talk about waste.
Do you know that if your space is clean,
zero-waste and organized,
you may feel happier?
Let's take a look at perhaps the messiest
part of everybody's home:
the fridge.
Some environmental experts recommend
that we put perishables into the drawers
and put the condiments at the door.
I hate to say this, but I disagree.
I don't think the fridge is designed
with human behavior in mind.
We often forget about the things
in the drawers, right,
out of sight, out of mind.
And that can lead to a lot
of food waste and emissions.
So what's the happy climate action here?
Feng shui your fridge.
(Laughter)
This is how I feng shui-ed my fridge.
By moving the perishables to the door
and the condiments into the drawers,
so I can catch things before they rot.
(Laughter)
I also FIFOd my fridge,
that is, “first in, first out,”
meaning, moving older items
to the front of the fridge
so I don't forget about them.
This way you can have
a zero-waste clean fridge
and you may feel happier.
Now beyond waste,
we have to talk about travel.
And here's the happy climate hack.
Instead of saying "drive less,"
we should say “drive more ...
people."
(Laughter)
Yes.
Some studies suggest
that the more time we spend
with our friends and family,
the happier we feel.
So what this means is that instead
of driving alone in our car,
(Laughter)
we should drive our friends.
Because carpooling can turn
those dreadful minutes behind the wheel
into joyful moments of socializing.
Or you can ditch the car
altogether and bike.
(Laughter)
Better yet, bike with your bunny.
Biking is virtually carbon-free.
And it also offers moderate exercise
that activates our endocannabinoid system.
And that contributes
to a sense of euphoria,
that's bikers high,
and greater mental well-being.
Now, we also know
that flying is carbon intensive.
One round trip between
Vancouver and New York
emits about half a ton
of greenhouse gases.
That's equivalent to 400 chicken burgers.
That's a lot of burgers.
But what's exciting here is that there's
a double happy climate hack here.
Ready?
First, bundle your trips.
This means combining
multiple trips into one
by meeting up with friends and family
and maybe doing a little
sightseeing in the region
to reap the happiness benefits
of social connection.
I flew here to New York from Vancouver
for this conference,
and I'm meeting up with my friends
in New York to be happier.
Second, cutting out unnecessary flights
can contribute to a sense
of time affluence
and that is a feeling
that you have enough time
to do what you want to do.
Studies have shown that people
who experience time affluence
tend to be happier
because [it] enhances
our sense of mindfulness,
autonomy and connection to others.
In a recent study, people felt happier
when they made a time-saving purchase
than a material purchase
because the time-saving purchase
made them feel less stressed.
So before you book your next flight,
think about all the other trips
you have to take in the future
and ask yourself whether
you can bundle these flights
to save your future self some time.
Now, do you want to know the best part
of this whole happy climate strategy?
It doesn't have to stay
at the individual level.
We can actually call for happy climate
policies that governments can enact
so that everyone can get a chance
to take these happy climate actions.
Let me give you an example.
Cities should invest more
in climate-friendly infrastructure
like bike lanes,
so more people get to bike.
Cities can also invest more
in nature-based solutions,
like urban green spaces,
that not only help cool the city down
during the summer,
but they also provide space
to take a walk,
to meet your neighbors,
to walk your bunny,
and then you can feel happier.
In fact, some studies show
that taking a walk in nature
makes people feel happier
than taking a walk on a city street.
I think you get the gist here.
And I encourage you to take a moment
and think about the actions
you can take in your own life
that not only reduce emissions,
but also can make yourself feel happier.
There's probably a lot of those
in this sweet spot,
so please get creative,
because the bottom line is this:
we need to change
the narrative on climate action.
We need to make climate action feel good
because if we get this right,
our future will indeed be happy.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)